tu es plus coloriage phenom donnez moi
ça c'est un peu tard pour commencer
l'entraînement tu auras pas
[Musique]
allongez-vous tu déconnes roger vous
traînez
on est cher
oui c'est parti
on a l'habitude
on va y arriver
coût
il faut que je m'engage je peux pas
rester ici pendant que les autres se
battent pour moi au questionnaire et il
le faut je vais travailler c'est pour
sauver des gens pas pour aller les tuer
s'il est trop tard
thierry anti incendie
qui va me demander ma main jour ou quoi
je sais pas trop tu le très beau que moi
tu ne le saura que se situe le demande
je peux alors c'était le temps de tout
mon coeur alors qu'est ce que tu veux
m'épouser
je dis oui oui je veux bien
le capitaine nous attendons mon colonel
vous attendez quoi de soldats dos j'ai
toujours rêvé d'être naissant j'ai passé
l'été à l'école
[Musique]
je peux pas rester ici pendant que les
autres se battent pour moi
tu t'imagines que cette guerre va coller
avec des principes pendant que les
autres vont prendre des vies moi je suis
en sauver ça va être ma façon de servir
voici un petit cadeau du gouvernement
des états unis
il a été conçu pour éradiquer la nuit
désolé sergent je touche pas au ca
ne tuez pas non monsieur vous savez que
ça peut arriver de tuer pendant une
guerre
le solde à dos ne croit pas à la
violence
ne comptez donc pas sur lui pour vous
sauver au combat
[Musique]
pour moi c'est pas une histoire de
religion je crois que c'est de la
lâcheté
je suis tombée amoureuse de toi parce
que tu étais différentes et septembre
est-ce que tu risque la prison comment
je pourrais rester moi même si j'arrête
de faire tousser dans quoi je crois
dans ce monde qui fait tout pour se
détruire
ça me semble pas une si mauvaise idée de
vouloir essayer de recoller un peu les
morceaux saltanov vous êtes libre
d'affronter l'enfer du champ de bataille
sans aucune arme pour vous protéger
[Musique]
ces lettres à missy toi
il faut que vous venez voir
j'ai fait ça ça c'est le lâche
on voit retourner là-bas dumas
et il refuse qu'on dirait sans toi
[Musique]
m qui faire confiance
tu as intérêt à venir
pitié seigneur fait que jenson foot+
de plus
[Musique]